- Du belügst deine Familie immer noch.
Mit ihm?
Das ist eine Schande!
Als wir in Syrien lebten,
hast du nie gelogen.
Seit du dich mit ihm triffst, tust du das.
- Herr Al-Pascha, wir haben uns
nur zufällig getroffen.
- Glaubst du, ich bin ein Idiot?
Dieser Mann lügt mich an.
Er bringt dich dazu, zu lügen.
Ihr kauft sogar schon Alkohol!
Er ist kein Umgang für dich!
- Hey!
- Seit wann seht ihr euch schon?
- Es geht Sie überhaupt nichts an,
wen Ihre Tochter sieht.
- Es geht mich nichts an?
Es geht mich nichts an, wenn meine
Tochter ihr Leben wegwirft?
Was sind deine Erwartungen vom Leben?
Was sind deine Perspektiven?
Du hast keine!
Wie willst du für meine Tochter sorgen?
- Ich liebe ihn, Papa!
- Ich liebe dich auch, Selma.
Du bist meine einzige Tochter!
Deshalb verbiete ich dir, ihn zu sehen.
Zu deinem eigenen Wohl!
- Das können Sie nicht.
- Selma!